hey guys so i'm about to do the als ice
bucket challenge now we are doing this
challenge in honor of the inishko family
who's from my hometown pittsburgh
pennsylvania they're a family friend
who's been personally affected by this
disease so if you guys would like to
also donate to the family directly i
will be putting a link in the
description so go check that out and now
i'm tagging some friends to also do this
challenge so i'm tagging cat riffic
tyler ward and jim carrey
he's actually not my friend but
if he wants to my friend that's fine so
now it's time to donate and get some ice
the internet and the ease eric's don't
put a camera
okay yay it just updated
pretty heavy
also gonna be setting it up as a thermal
camera so i want my video to be a little
bit different than most we have a gopro
we've got thermal camera we also have
another gopro so it's going to be a lot
of different angles good news the
buckets are arriving 45 minutes to find
ice machines all right let's do this in
the mail so i'm showing you guys right
now the thermal image of the buckets
they do indeed look quite chilly okay
hey
i'm slow ready one two three
it's healthy